well first of all it starts with the
mission of the company and dude does the
leadership of the company are they
committed to the mission and the values
of the company Goldman Sachs for
instance John Whitehead wrote the
mission and values of the company in the
early 1980s 25 years ago and he wrote
about the clients interests always come
first is the leadership committed to
that proposition we believe in teamwork
over stars is a leadership committed to
that don't choose a leader is not who
watch the star system if you believe in
creating a meritocracy which Goldman is
which Medtronic is which ExxonMobil or I
serve on the board is then you better
choose someone who believes in
meritocracy and not pushing up a lot of
its political buddies and not playing a
power game and that's what you've seen a
lot of these failed leaders they were
Morrison personal power accumulation and
their own personal self aggrandizement
and by the way I don't even think it was
money I think the money conveyed a
certain status that they were looking
for and it was a way of offsetting some
internal feelings that weren't so good
and so I think we've chosen the wrong
leaders for the wrong reason I mean
choosing people based on their charisma
instead their character when choosing
people based on their image instead of
their integrity I mean choosing people
more for style and substance if you
choose people for that why are you
surprised when you don't get people of
great character and great values and so
I think boards have failed in many many
cases now the corporate boards are
finally waking up and I hope that Wall
Street boards are going to wake up the
city grew bored was totally asleep when
it when it didn't manage Sandy Weill and
let him create the kind of instability
he did and then chose Chuck prints at
the lawyer to take over
yes yes I I don't believe in the Big
Bang supermarket I don't think you can
argue against absolute size like take
the exons the world's largest company I
don't think you can say X on it's too
big let's break it up exons focusing on
what it does well oil and gas okay
delivering in the most efficient way to
the most people and you know and it's
been doing it in with the least amount
of energy usage it's very committed to
that but in Goldman Sachs's focus on
being investment bank you know I'm not
even sure I think you can't put the
genie back in the bottle but i'm not i'm
not so confident they get her a glass
steagle was a good thing dick kovacevic
a very successful CEO wells fargo for 20
years most successful commercial bank he
would never get no mess in banking he
was going to stay the course and I
talked to him by wachovia why do you do
walk ova cuz he took a huge hit from
some of their trading activities he said
we wanted it for the franchise and
that's where they'll get you watch
they'll have that eat that east of the
Mississippi franchise or the West in
Mississippi there'll be a great
commercial bank as what they'll be but
they understand their mission they
didn't try to be all things to all
people and I think that was to failing a
Sandy Weill at Citigroup